well qui enlève donc le mont blanc d'une
certaine gamme de ses produits c'est la
polémique qui a enflammé les réseaux
sociaux ce week-end alors va-t-on trop
loin cette on a des revendications
communautaires qui vont plutôt vers la
division que vous voyez est relativement
ou au contraire est-ce une bonne
décision de lutte contre le racisme
c'est l'objet de notre face à face pour
en débattre nous sommes avec fatima
benomar militants fondatrice du
collectif féministe les effrontés
bonsoir fatima benomar merci d'être avec
nous pour en débattre thaïs militante du
mouvement politique génération
identitaire dont soir mademoiselle merci
d'être avec nous et glissements la
marque de cosmétiques donc très célèbre
qui supprime les mots blanc clair
blanchissement blanchissant de ces
produits on va commencer par vous thaïs
est ce que ça vous choque vous faites
partie des gens qui ont été voilà très
choqué ce week end à cette décision
le real paris a fait le choix de la
soumission idéologique aux militants
anti blanc de black keys matters après
c'est ce choix de l'acheter finalement
s'est soldée par un échec cuisant de
deux par deux par deux côtés c'est à
dire que le premier cela a engendré un
appel au boycott massif sur les réseaux
sociaux que des dizaines de milliers
d'internautes ont suivi
d'autre part la validation politique
qu'il recherchait auprès des militants
anti blancs de la classe amateur n'a pas
fonctionné il nous racontait que du
mépris et j'oserais dire encore encore
pire vous avez des militants qui disait
que ce n'était pas assez que ces
produits auraient dû être retiré de la
vente et que le real devait cesser toute
commercialisation de ses produits
je pense notamment à rokhaya diallo qui
l'avait qu'il avait demandé sur twitter
alors fait il m'a benomar effectivement
ça créé un tollé
ce week-end avec un boycott notamment
des produits vous comprenez cette
réaction ou c'est un faux débat pour
vous et c'est une très bonne décision
qu'a prise au l'oréal ben pour moi c'est
une décision en demi teinte à 6 jeux se
dire c'est à dire que l'oréal elle
supprime les mots blanc et blanche
ce moment mais elle va maintenir en
vente a priori la vente de ses
cosmétiques et qui vont éclaircir les
poëles fait de l'argent sans un millier
ça marche et 2 milliards de dollars en
inde en jamaïque aux états unis donc
c'est un coup de com qui retire les mois
mais qui ne retire pas des produits
ultra toxique un du marché
le blanchiment c'est une technique de
dépigmentation avec des produits
chimiques qui est très répandue en
afrique ou en asie parce que la
blancheur ce sont des canaux des canons
de beauté très imposé même en france
d'ailleurs à la camorra disais que iliad
un directeur artistique lui avais dit qu
elle pourrait toucher plus de personnes
si elles s'éclaircissent et la pauvre on
sait que ce sont des pratiques photoshop
quand il ya des mannequins noirs etc et
donc non seulement c'est un problème
d'identité c'est à dire que ces femmes
sont incités dès le plus jeune âge à
détester leur apparence et le fait
d'être noir mais c'est un sujet aussi de
santé publique parce que ces produits
sont hyper toxiques et provoque des
cancers etc
il ya des pays comme le rwanda le
sénégal le ghana qui les interdisent
même si du coup ils vont finir dans le
marché au noir
donc moi je suis plutôt un soutien à des
collectifs de jeunes femmes comme
esprits des bennes ou nuls coup quand
sénégal qui au contraire valorise les
femmes noires pour ne pas avoir honte de
leur apparence et j'espère que ces
mobilisations vont changer les pratiques
du monde cosmétiques de même pas
seulement que sur s'assure aussi la
minceur exagéré et c'est dans le monde
du mannequinat par exemple enfin tout ce
qui touche l'apparence des femmes ela
s'est aggravée quand ce sont des femmes
racisées c'est à dire que il y aura
toujours ses produits sur la vente qui
leur font passer le message que leur
peau noire n'est pas belle ou désirable
en tant que tel thaïs d'une certaine
manière pour vous est-ce que l'oréal a
agi sous le coup de la pression en
voulant comme le dit fatima venmar faire
une forme de deux coupes comme dans un
contexte évidemment que l'on s'est tendu
par les manifestations notamment aux
états unis
c'est tout simplement cédé à la pression
et s'offrir un coup de communication où
elle a réfléchi peut-être à sa stratégie
cette marque c'était la pression oui et
c'est une soumission idéologique c'est
se soumettre à ses militants anti blanc
de l'animateur à leurs revendications
mais j'ai envie de dire quelle est la
prochaine étape
on supprime le mot blanc du dictionnaire
on supprime les publicités pour
dentifrice qui parle de blanchir les
dents on va renvoyer qu on est quand
même dans une dynamique complètement
grotesque qui est qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas normal ça veut dire quoi pour
vous il ya une forme je caricature
peut-être votre propos mais allons
jusqu'au bout c'est une forme de presque
de racisme anti blanc pour vous thaïs
oui complètement le racisme anti blanc
voilà c'est nous faire qu'on fasse
comprendre aux blancs qu'ils ne sont qu
ils ne sont qu ils sont qu'il y en a
trop qu'ils sont trop nombreux
qu'on l'ait on les efface voilà on est
on efface la simple mention de leur
couleur de peau
le racisme anti blanc après au delà de
ça c'est quand même un phénomène qui est
très répandue qui touche le plus le plus
de monde qui est le plus la haine la
plus violente dans son expression qui
est la plus la plus massive
d'ailleurs c'est un racisme c'est une
haine qu'on a pu quantifier puisque deux
chercheurs de l'ined avait effectué une
enquête en 2016 qui révélait que 10
millions de français avaient déjà été
confronté au racisme anti blanc et et
voilà fatima benomar vous n'avez pas le
sentiment justement que c'est peut-être
voilà une action parce que d'abord on
précise que l'oréal n'est pas la seule
marque il ya plusieurs marques qui
suivent le pas voilà qui réfléchissent
oncle ben et c'était à changer leur
chose d'ailleurs une une marque de
dentifrice justement vous en parliez il
ya vraiment une pression est ce que
c'est la bonne méthode et est ce que
quand même vous vous êtes d'accord avec
les propos de tennis ça peut voilà aussi
suggéré un racisme anti blanc ou pas du
tout selon vous c'est étrange de parler
de racisme anti blanc parce qu'on
demandait à des femmes noires de se
blanchir juste en train de revenir sur
sa sur la base du canon de beauté qui
mettrait une hiérarchie dans les beautés
et où les calmants de beauté se serait
dit les éclairs
donc comment peut-on se plaindre en
effacerait rouen stigmatiserait les
femmes blanches alors qu'on demandait en
fait été une réaction au fait demander à
des femmes noires de rentrer plus dans
les codes physique des femmes blanches
donc je trouve ça très étrange comme
retournement de deux situations et par
rapport
et ça il faut bien comprendre qu'on
héritiers de société ou se sont ou le
sexe et la race la construction de la
race ont fonctionné comme des systèmes
de marquage arbitraire pour justement
construire des rayés archi où on a
considéré que les blancs étaient
supérieurs au noir les hommes étaient
supérieurs aux femmes
et c'est ça qui a permis à la fois l'
esclavage les patriarcats la
colonisation et c'est ce qui a permis en
fait qu'aujourd'hui on soit héritier
d'un système on retrouve pour objectiver
les choses tout en bas de l'échelle
sociale c'est à dire des personnes qui
vont être les plus dévalorisé on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire c'était les
femmes les personnes racisées qui
s'occupait du nettoyage de nos rues de
nos gars de toilette etc
au plus bas de l'échelle et ce sont bien
elles qui sont confrontés aux
discriminations à l'embauché au travail
etc
donc c'est bien ce système qu'on est en
train de dénoncer et en fait à chaque
fois commis à lui le mouvement mis tous
très vite s'est posé le débat en ces
termes est ce qu'on va trop loin
est-ce que ça va perturber toute la
société de poser la question de la
domination masculine et du patriarcat et
là il se passe un peu la même chose du
moment que la question du racisme est au
centre du débat tout public
tout de suite on met des barrières à ce
débat et on se dit est ce que déjà on va
trop loin
non je pense qu'il faut tout simplement
comprendre ce débat il ya quand même le
défenseur des droits jacques toubon qui
a produit un très bon
travail de synthèse qui est objective en
fait qui montre des enquêtes et des
statistiques sur la réalité des
violences racistes qui les points
aveugles et silencieux sur les
discriminations ethno racial et c'est
sur ça qu'il faut se baser tout
simplement pour avancer vers une société
égalitaire alors en tout cas ça a fait
réagir jusqu'à la sphère politique ce
week end son repose d'écouter ce tweet
de philippe deviner le groupe l'oréal a
décidé de retirer les mots blanc
blanchissant claire de tous ses produits
destinés à uniformiser la peau indiqué
le géant français dans un communiqué
marketing racialiste aujourd'hui si ce
fleuron français fait peser sur ses
clients la honte de leur couleur de peau
au nom de cette idéologie délirante je
demande à tous les gaulois réfractaires
d'arrêter l'oréal à leur taille et vous
vous allez arrêter
l'oréal fait qu'on vous l'utilisez pas
cela dit mais ça vous ferait en tout cas
de ne pas l'acheter même s'il ya un
produit vous plaisait oui j'avais
d'ailleurs est posté une vidéo qui a
assez tourné notamment sur twitter où je
t'ai de manière assez symbolique le
l'unique produits l'oréal finalement que
je possédais chez moi non clairement je
ne souhaite pas rentrer dans ce jeu je
rejette
je rejette cette volonté cette cette
lâcheté de la part de l'oréal je
n'achèterai clairement plus reproduits
fatima benomar sur ses propos de
philippe de villiers a également marine
le pen un jury que vous êtes
complètement quand les idées de marine
le pen mais voilà qui explique que ça ne
fait que diviser que ça engendre de la
violence plutôt que de l'apaisement ce
que ça vous lui accordez effectivement
voilà un petit bénéfice du doute est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression que ce
débat divise plus qu'il rassemble et
qu'il apaise en tout cas en fait dès
qu'on résiste et qu'on veut changer le
système il y à ce procès de la division
et du coup les personnes qui dénonçaient
des violents systémique de la
discrimination de la stigmatisation et
serra vont être incités à aller vers le
statu quo donc très vite dès qu'on met
commence à nous pas taper sur les doigts
mais arrêtez de parler
mitsou vous êtes en train de dresser les
femmes contre les hommes qu on
intériorise un peu une sorte de
culpabilité dit revenons statu quo et là
c'est la même chose qui est au centre
des débats c'est la question raciale
je pense que ça va faire mal dans les
sociétés qui ont un peu mis de côté ce
débat là c'est sûr que ça va se faire
dans un peu de douleur mais ça je pense
vraiment que c'est une crispation assez
française par exemple moi je suis très
cinéphile et aux états unis
il y a un nombre énorme de films qui
traitent de la question de la guerre du
vietnam
c'est quelque chose qui a irrigué toute
la société suite au tout le mouvement de
jeunes qui a contesté la l'économie est
là et la guerre du vietnam en france
quand on a fait un débat sur la question
de la guerre d'algérie c'est à dire avec
le film les indigènes tout de suite
c'était d'infini nombre de plateaux télé
à la la mais est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de faire pénitence et de vouloir
voir notre passé en face et du cou ça
divise
je pense que au contraire ce qu'il faut
c'est voir son histoire dans les yeux ne
plus la rentrer partielle et partiale et
accepter ces débats et faire en sorte de
pouvoir avancer ensemble
mais ce n'est pas en éludant les
questions parce que bah ça risque de
créer du débat et la division elle vient
plutôt des problèmes qui sont mis de
côté que du moment où on les met sur la
place publique
donc je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur
de ce débat et ne pas se contenter du
statu quo merci en tout cas à toutes les
deux fatima benomar thaïs d'avoir été
avec nous pour débattre
en direct sur rt france merci